I wouldn't be human without having the
first question to ask you how are you
how are you doing and how is this
journey been for you since you left
Montreal were you here tonight yes I was
there in Vegas and I was gay because I'm
I'm really doing well like I said
tonight on stage maybe I don't remember
what I said exactly but I guess if I'm
fine my kids are fine if my kids are
fine I'm fine and that's the most
important thing my children are doing
really well and I'm doing really well I
have to stand strong for today and for
my kids for myself for what's up what's
to come for tomorrow and I don't know
Renee gave everything to me um and
wonderful children on top of the rest of
my journey through the business um
whether i want to be on stage or not I
feel so fulfilled of love still him
reminding him up in my life I still feel
him very much I go pretty well with his
new life to be honest with you it was I
loved him too much to see him suffer the
way he did last three years so I am very
grateful that this part of his life is
over with I am ecstatic to be home I
could have talked about the journey that
I'm having in Montreal is just amazing I
still cannot believe that through the
whole show people were standing up and
and so high I was like I don't know how
I'm gonna sleep I try to put a pj on
kind of to put myself comfortable to
kind of get me to slow down with my
energy but um
I've always been very welcome home every
time but this was this was big this was
big but emotionally we're worse we're
good